tamara vous avez suivi aujourd'hui
toutes les réactions en russie et cet
attentat on sent qu'il est brand toute
la classe politique dans le pays et la
classe médiatique aussi et surtout je
vous dirais dont elle faisait partie
cette femme parce qu'elle avait beau
dire se décrire comme journaliste
faisait du journalisme sur le terrain on
n'a qu'à regarder l'ensemble de son
oeuvre sur son sur ses comptes à elle ou
dans les médias russes pour voir quelle
était en fait qu une activiste politique
une île thèse est une militante qui
comme beaucoup de ses commentateurs en
russie qui travaille au service de
l'état sesay il faut encore l'apologie
de la guerre donc évidemment tous ceux
qui travaillent de près ou de loin dans
la machine de propagande du kremlin sont
sous le choc aujourd'hui savez ces gens
qui disaient quand même dans la quiétude
depuis les bus la guerre depuis le début
de la guerre à l'abri du danger et qu'il
se rend compte aujourd'hui qu'un dans la
quiétude de moscou même à des centaines
de kilomètres du franc ils peuvent être
soit ciblé son époque il est à l'origine
ou encore être sacrifiée par leur propre
gouvernement
parce que ça c'est une des thèses qui
est explorée aujourd'hui pour pour
expliquer cette attente web est
justement parlez-nous de ses thèses la
qui flottent un petit peu partout parce
que qu'ils avaient vraiment intérêt
selon vous à nous faire disparaître
cette jeune femme à première vue
personnes et s'est cru le dire comme ça
étant donné que c'est quand même
dramatique ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'elle n'avait pas de valeur
particulière puisque son père alexander
double même si on dit qu'il était un
allié de vladimir poutine c'est pas des
gens qui étaient indispensables au
kremlin et vous vous demandez aux reçus
aujourd'hui qui étaient ces deux là
prête à parier que la majorité ne le
savent pas donc qui a intéressés il ya
plusieurs thèses ça dépend comment on se
sert de l'assassinât pour répondre à
cette question le fsb la russie accuse
l'ukraine on dit preuve à l'appui ça y
est on ne fait l enquête une enquête
éclair
en moins de 24 heures on est identifié
une ukrainienne ont dit celle qui
télécommandé par kiev a perpétré
l'attentât de publier sa photo ont dit
qu elle s'est enfuie dans les pays
baltes c'est assez boiteux parce qu'on
n'a pas toutes les preuves pour
justifier cette thèse là et encore une
fois quel est l'intérêt de l'ukraine de
faire disparaître cette jeune femme
cette jeune journaliste l'autre thèse
est une possibilité très certainement
c'est un groupe d'opposition souterrain
en russie qui veut déstabiliser le
régime et envoyer un message de façon
très brutale c'est pas impossible
d'ailleurs il ya un groupe qui s'appelle
l'armée républicaine nationale de russie
qui a publié un manifeste pour
revendiquer l'attentât mais encore
langue très peu de détails et donc la
dernière thèse est celle qui est
beaucoup discuté aujourd'hui ce serait
la teste les crèmes laits et l'orchestré
lui même cet attentat pourquoi d'abord
parce que ça fait partie du mode de
sopera dit souvent réussi mais aussi
pour envoyer un message
alors qu'on s'apprête à souligner les
six mois du début de l'invasion alors
que l'ukraine s'apprête à célébrer c'est
très symbolique 31 ans d'indépendance en
pleine guerre mercredi mais elle a dit
se donner encore une fois une
justification pour intensifier les
frappes parce que regarder comment
serait renier sa plus de prétexte au
godinand foot n'a pas besoin de prêter
qui mène cette guerre déjà depuis six
mois sophie regarder demain il va tenir
monsieur poutine une cérémonie pour la
décorer daria doubina de la médaille du
courage ce fait la plus haute
distinction
qu'un président peut offrir en russie on
va faire une martyre et pour le peuple
russe qui est peut-être at-il eu cette
guerre avec les sanctions et avec ce que
ça amène en russie comme nouvelle
réalité pourrait regarder ces images on
se demandait ce qu'on n'a pas raison de
continuer lui-même dépensier là
devraient avoir un impact absolument de
la guerre merci beaucoup tamare on va se
parler cette semaine longue de cet
anniversaire de ce jour de
l'indépendance en ukraine et de ceci moi
aussi quand elle ça piétine quand même
beaucoup de villes sont sur un pied
d'alert interrompt les services de métro
vont prolonger le couvre feu par son
absence est vraiment des les attaques
peut-être plus violent que merci tamara
au revoir